[Music]
Xenoblade Chronicles definitive edition
is just as vast and fantastical as it
was in 2010 while not every aspect has
aged gracefully monolith softs
role-playing game has withstood the test
of time and further cements itself as
one of the most memorable JRPGs in the
last decade although xenoblade
chronicles opening hours may seem
standard fare for JRPGs story-wise what
sets it apart right from the get-go is
its setting years before the events of
the game two massive titans bionis and
mechonis were locked in a devastating
battle of unfathomable proportions one
day two titans froze and life started to
pop up on the backs of these enormous
figures to put things in perspective
colony 9 where the protagonist shulk
lives and the sprawling plains in lakes
surrounding it are located near the
bionis ankle big open areas alone are
nothing new these days but the way
Monell is soft plays with scale makes
this world enticing massive beasts that
tower over shulk in his party roamed the
wilds and huge natural formations loom
over every region all of this is
accompanied by an enchanting soundtrack
that has been stuck in my head for weeks
[Music]
definitive edition has undergone an
impressive graphical overhaul the
characters and textures have been
redesigned to give the game a sharper
and more defined look akin to Z no blade
chronicles to the real star of the show
though is the updated UI while Xenoblade
still has some incredibly dense menus in
stat pages the new interface is much
easier on the eyes and does a far better
job of putting the most important
information in front and center
combat plays out the same as it did in
the original you have a basic auto
attack in a series of arts tied to
cooldown meters much like an MMO you'll
need to chain arts abilities and unique
talents a specialized attack tied to a
specific party member in order to take
down enemies efficiently
although the combat may not be as flashy
as xenoblade chronicles - it certainly
doesn't lack depth shulk is the main
character but you can play as any
character in your party for most battles
and each character has their own
strategy with different arts and talents
to master combat rarely gets doler
tedious thanks to how differently all
these characters play as your party
lands critical hits a segmented gauge
will fill up in the top left corner you
can use a third of the gauge to revive a
fallen teammate or if you fill it you
can unleash a chained attack this will
freeze the battle and each of your party
members can use a single art matching
the same color arts will inflict more
damage and with a bit of luck and high
affinity for each other your party can
continue the chain attack for 15 turns
dealing a massive amount of damage
meeting the requirements for lengthy
chain attacks can take a while but
landing them properly and eviscerating a
boss's health is incredibly satisfying
as good as combat is it can be
frustrating at times mostly due to your
companion AI because you can only
control one character in any given
battle you rely heavily on party members
to pull off specific combos just because
I inflict a break art with show up does
not guarantee Ryan will follow up with a
topple art halting my combo before it
even gets started considering how many
battles you take part in B's AI issues
are rare but that doesn't make them any
less annoying although Zeno blades
combat demands a lot of you definitive
edition adds a few new difficulty
options that can take the edge off for
players who might be struggling or
alternatively even the playing field for
those who have mastered
mechanics these difficulty options come
in the form of casual mode and expert
mode and can be adjusted at any point in
your adventure as you'd expect casual
mode makes battles significantly easier
across the board even veteran players
may find some use out of casual mode
because it can cut down on the grinding
thanks to quicker and easier battles
expert mode on the other hand doesn't
actually make the game harder rather it
lets you manually level up and level
down your party members outside of
battle every time you are an experienced
a portion of that XP will be set aside
you can then use that experience pool to
level up your characters further or
d-level them on a whim the inclusion of
this mode may seem strange at first but
if you are the type of player who likes
to complete every side quest kill every
unique monster and min/max your
characters you will undoubtedly find
yourself over leveled for a majority of
the game expert mode is a smart way to
combat that better yet just like casual
mode you can turn expert mode on and off
whenever you like
you can even enable casual mode and
expert mode at the same time to further
tune the difficulty
despite the updated look and improved
accessibility a handful of the game
systems and mechanics feel like
unnecessary bloat that add complexity
simply for the sake of complexity a
prime example of this is the affinity
chart system which tracks shulk's
reputation with settlements and the
relationships between various side
characters as you talk to named NPC's
they will register in your affinity
chart and if you complete quests for
them they may become linked to other
NPCs if you improve their relationship
by trading with them in completing side
quests you can improve shulk's overall
renown and a specific settlement on
paper the affinity chart sounds
impressive and to some extent it is it
was an ambitious idea in 2010 but the
execution remains clunky and convoluted
the result is a dizzying chart that
connects a bunch of forgettable
characters to one another by completing
dozens of repetitive fetch quests
fortunately xenoblade chronicles makes
it clear early on that you can ignore
the affinity chart altogether without
any consequences thankfully xenoblade
chronicles definitive edition does away
with the affinity chart in the excellent
new 20 our epilogue future connected
even though shulk's still plays a big
role in the epilogue the story is
centered around Mel
a party member from the original game as
she tries to figure out what happened to
her hometown Alchemist it's a bold move
to shine the spotlight on Melia rather
than shulk but it's one that ultimately
pays off Shulk story has already been
told and given how xenoblade chronicles
ends there are a lot of loose ends to
tie up with melea's story and character
without getting into spoilers and story
specifics future connected does an
excellent job at exploring the
repercussions and ramifications of
Xenoblade Chronicles final moments
thanks to future connected shorter
lengths there is little filler in the
narrative right from the beginning
monolith soft carries you from region to
region at a steady pace occasionally you
may stop to complete side quests and
grind out a few levels depending on your
difficulty settings but by and large
there is a steady momentum pushing you
through the epilogue future connected
also showcases some of monolith softs
best world creature and art design
rather than a bunch of smaller maps /
loading screens future connected takes
place on the bionis shoulder a massive
lush area with stunning vistas and
incredible architecture at every turn
well you will see some familiar
creatures roaming the wild there are a
host of new and impressive beasts and
bosses to take down including an
optional boss that will pose a
significant threat to those who aren't
adequately prepared the only aspect of
future connected that left me really
disappointed is that many important
characters from the original like Ryan
and Sharla played little to no role in
the epilogue well this does make sense
for the narrative it does mean that
throughout future connected you'll only
have access to a total of four party
members which leaves certain arts
abilities and play styles from the main
game behind though future connected does
lack some depth from the main game it
makes up for it with its focus narrative
and gorgeous world design more so than
Xenoblade Chronicles proper I felt
compelled to explore every corner of the
new area and complete every single side
quest while not every aspect of
xenoblade chronicles has aged as well as
others definitive edition proves that
Xenoblade Chronicles is still a
fantastic JRPG with an immense amount of
strategic depth vets still impressive in
2020 its bevy of improvements and
additions as well as its fantastic
epilogue still make this an adventure
worth embarking on a decade later
[Music]